[Music]
bell's told
500 times at the national cathedral in
memory of those killed
it's been just over a year since the u.s
recorded its first death from the
disease
more than 28 million people have been
infected
since then kristen salumi has more from
washington dc
president joe biden marked the somber
milestone from the white house
acknowledging the half million loss to
covet 19
not as a number but as individuals
the people we lost were extraordinary
they spanned generations
born in america immigrated to america
but just like that so many of them took
their final breath
alone in america
as a nation we can't accept such a cruel
fate
while we've been fighting this pandemic
for so long
we have to resist becoming numb to the
sorrow
after addressing the nation the
president headed outside for a moment of
silence 500 candles
lit for 500 000 dead and we're still not
out of it
a half a million deaths it's just
it's it's terrible it is historic we
haven't seen anything even close to this
the grim milestone comes after winter
storms stalled vaccination efforts in
parts of the nation
so far just over 80 percent of the doses
that are available
have been administered health officials
say they should be back on track
this week vaccinating at a rate of 1.8
million shots per day
while hospitalizations and fatalities
remain high
the most of any country in the world
they've begun to decline
dramatically cover 19 in the united
states has been declining for five weeks
with the seven day average
dropping 74 percent since the peak seven
day average on january 11th
the president has promised to vaccinate
100 million americans in his first 100
days in
office and white house officials expect
to meet that goal
but that may be small comfort to those
who've lost a loved one
nevertheless the president offered the
grieving a message of hope
you're going to be ok and to heal he
said
we must remember kristin salumi al
jazeera
washington